Indonesia as vice president use of color
led tributes to the dead at the siren
mass grave around 50,000 tsunami victims
were buried there no one knows the
number for sure authorities hastily
buried their bodies in the aftermath of
the disaster the tsunami devastated
Archer province most of the nearly
170,000 Indonesians who died that day
perished there a massive underwater
quake triggered that tsunami mountainous
waves of up to 35 meters high devastated
coastal areas around the Indian Ocean
people lost everything they had homes
and businesses turned to debris today
Indonesia has rebuilt much of what
they'd lost speaking in siren color
thank the international community for
help I've taken up law without all you
suppose all your participation in our
the tsunami laid waste to coastal areas
around the Indian Ocean kanyakumari a
small town on the southernmost tip of
India was devastated many of the
survivors have since moved inland
fearing another tsunami in Victoria this
woman says her younger sister died that
day and that she has come almost 500
kilometres to take part in the prayers
here I can but generally I will partner
allegheny key for many the pain of
having lost their loved ones is still
fresh many are desperate for closure
they're lost relatives were never found
for years that was also the case for I
pour from Myanmar she lost her 20 year
old daughter who was killed when the
tsunami hit Thailand where she had moved
to work her best friend couldn't save
her and watched as she was swept away by
the waves whenever I see school children
coming home I feel like my daughter's
coming home too I feel so empty when I
see them in their uniforms me go check
made me go yeah but she eventually
learned that her daughter's body had
been recovered and buried in an
anonymous grave here in Southern
thailand authorities found her ID
personal belongings and DNA analyses
have helped them identify many other
bodies a decade later I pues healing
process can finally begin she's hoping
her daughter's body will be brought back
home but many of those who survived the
disaster are still wrestling with their
harrowing memories many European
survivors have returned to car luck
beach here in Thailand to commemorate
that day the chat initiative doctors ice
machines nothing I had never thought
that the 10-year anniversary would touch
me the way it does because I've been
back many times since but being here
with all the other people does create a
special bond may we invite his ex
Thailand's official commemoration have
been held 50 kilometres further inland
sounds of comfort a decade after the
disaster but some wonder if the world's
will ever truly heal